[Music]
you okay
I literally can't see anything at either
one of my eyes say what I can't see
anything
I'm just ready open it something to hurt
yes what did you do to it I don't know
buddy I just wasn't sleeping I can't
leave see it's like black I just got
like a little big circle right here my
site has got worse and worse over the
years but right now I can't see a thing
and I'm scared are you no I can't see
that's just a doctor and I'm being
serious it's she's downstairs oh come on
yeah I ain't never cease to go before it
well me I know but it's been like bother
my hurt somebody you know I've been
having it like really bad migraines it's
just like yours I was so bad I don't
know the last time I had an eye exam
I'm sure listen to Gino and went earlier
and then maybe this wouldn't be
happening
yeah weirdo Billy being asked she's over
here come on
where's the door Oh watch out jellybeans
Alana
grab the real Oh nobody like Betty we
got to work together here Alana
come on we got to take your mom to the
hospital baby I'm gonna call the doctor
tell him to meet us at the hospital
[Music]